on va tester les nouvelles
fonctionnalités d' du Samsung Galaxy S24
ultra il y en a énormément pour venir
échanger avec des gens pour faire des
photos bref vous allez voir c'est très
complet on est ici aujourd'hui à San
Francisco on va en profiter pour venir
tout tester parce que bien évidemment je
suis français ici il parle anglais ça
vous aura pas échappé on va donc aller
parler avec des gens essayer de repérer
la ville voir ce qu'on peut faire avec
lia dans ce nouveau smartphone vous
allez voir c'est vraiment
[Musique]
incroyable première fonctionnalité je
suis par exemple dans mes photos en
train de me balader je me dis tiens il y
a un truc qui m'intéresse qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce truc je me rappelle pas je
le vois et bien ce que je fais c'est que
j'appuie au milieu ici ça vient
déclencher la fonction entourée pour
chercher par Google directement sur mon
galaxy S24 ultra donc là j'entoure ça
vient chercher ça sort directement
Memorial Church je vois que c'est
l'église de Stanford en Californie et là
je me dis mais ouais j'y étais forcément
vous êtes en train de vous balader
directement là sur Instagram et je vois
qu'il y a une bibliothèque je me dis
tiens qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc où
est-ce que c'est hop là qu'est-ce que je
fais je fais un appui long ensuite je
viens entourer cette partie là je crois
que c'est une bibliothèque en Corée je
sais pas où et là ça me le dit c'est la
starfield librrairie qui situe
directement à cou donc vous avez accès
directement à vos résultats de recherche
très facilement en laissant appuyer
votre doigt au milieu entouré pour
charercher c'est parti comme ça vous
savez
tout un truc qui est vraiment cool aussi
c'est au niveau de la photo ils sont
vraiment venus forcément là travailler
avec Deia ils ont fait quelques Choin un
peu différents le grand tank c'est du
200 mégapixel surtout là où l'année
dernière vous aviez un téléobjectif x 3
optique et on en X 10 optique deuxème
téléobjectif là vous avez toujours un
premier téléobjectif de x 3 optique en
10 mégapixel sauf que le deuxième qui
était en x 100 optique passe en X 5
optique alors rassurez-vous avant le
capteur était 10 mégapixel sur cette
focale là aujourd'hui c'est un capteur
de 50 mégapixel avec des photodiodes qui
sont 1,6 fois plus grandes permet de
capter plus de lumière et tout ça en
plus avec de l derrière déjà le truc qui
est dingue là vous le voyez on est en
pleine lumière il y a vraiment beaucoup
de lumière tout de suite et bien on a un
écran qui va jusqu'à 2600 nit ce qui
fait que vous voyez vachement bien bien
même en pleine lumière donc ça c'est
déjà extrêmement impressionnant donc là
je vais vous montrer c'est le X 1 vous
avez bien évidemment le X 06 plus large
et ensuite faites vos optique x 2 le X 2
en fait et bien c'est sur votre capteur
200 mégapixel il va venir croper à
l'intérieur du capteur mais c'est un
équivalent zoom optique donc c'est en
fait comme un X 2 optique même si c'est
pas réellement un X 2 optique vous avez
le X 3 optique vous arrivez ensuite sur
un X 5 optique donc ça c'est
effectivement premier téléobjectif
deuxième téléobjectif et ensuite grâce à
toute la suce qu'ils ont fait au niveau
hardware plus il a vous arrivez sur un
FO
qualité optique où là ça va être
complètement dingue au niveau du rendu
vous le voyez puis le truc qui est fou
une fois de plus c'est la stabilisation
moi je tremble j'ai un tremblement
essentiel et bien regardez pour venir
shooter ça vous le stabilise quand même
c'est vraiment impressionnant et après
on peut monter bien évidemment x 30
c'est quand même vachement cool et je
vous montre les photos dans quelques
instants et puis bien évidemment le fo00
le Space zoom et vous avez ensuite votre
caméra de selfie alors là on est à
contrejour bon c'est pas ce qu' a de
mieux mais on peut bienenir le faire
également et puis l'autre élément qui
est intéressant ici c'est que comme vous
avez de l'IA à l'intérieur de votre
smartphone et bien il va venir analyser
les différents zones lorsque vous allez
prendre votre photo et même juste avant
que vous déclenchiez c'est-à-dire que
lorsque vous êtes en train de venir
prendre une photo voyez par exemple là
je suis comme ça je vois ma scène et lui
il va venir analyser les personnes qui
passent il va venir analyser le building
il va venir analyser si par exemple là
je suis comme ça il va venir analyser et
bien le totem bref tous les éléments
pris individuellement pour venir
maximiser la couleur pour venir
maximiser le contraste la luminosité
tout ça c'est cool parce que ça se fait
grâce à lia qu'on va voir ici à
l'intérieur ce qui vous permettra
d'avoir le meilleur rendu au niveau des
photos aujourd'hui possible sur un
Samsung Galaxy S ici on se parle d'un
smartphone dans la gamme S la gamme S
c'est la gamme photo performance et une
fois de plus la photo est vraiment au
rendez-vous grand angle on vient dzoomer
ultra grand angle on vient zoomer x 2 x
3 x 5 x 10 ça bouge vraiment pas sur le
X 10 regardez le détail que vous avez là
c'est absolument incroyable x 30 et on
va jusqu'au x 100 et là le FO 100 je
trouve assez intéressant pourquoi parce
que le Space zoom souvent c'est un petit
peu compliqué et là comme on est sur un
noir écrit sur un blanc et bien il vient
réellement grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle analyser et totalement
corriger ce qu'on a jeou ça vraiment
vraiment bien là pareil on va se
retrouver là je trouve ça efficace grand
angle ultra grand angle et on vient se
rapprocher on vient zoomer regardez-moi
le détail que vous avez là c'est juste
absolument incroyable également là en
mode portrait ça marche vraiment bien
regardez-moi là le détourage au niveau
des cheveux c'est super super super
précis j'adore aussi avec le contrejour
qu'on a là on voit bien tous les détails
le contrejour est extrêmement bien
maîtriser sur le grand angle également
sur lera grand angle et ça c'est quand
même très très bien en venons zoomer
également ça fonctionne là on va venir
voir il s'appelle près du soleil le
bateau et surtout on part quand même de
là donc on est extrêmement loin l'hôtel
de ville de San Francisco qu'on a là
avec le coucher de soleil ici et les
ambiances avec la fumée qui sort ici des
bouges des goûts j'adore cette ambiance
je trouve ça vraiment super cool et une
fois de plus la photo est totalement
sublimé vous voyez les détails que vous
venez retrouver ici c'est très très très
efficace ici de la même manière elle la
tombée du soleil gestion des lumières
qui est vraiment très très bien maîtrisé
sur le grand angle mais également sur
l'ultra grand angle en venant zoomer
également une fois de plus c'est très
juste j'adore cette ambi ambiance là
avec cette bouche de métro c'est super
efficace et là je vous emmène à Stanford
grosse université à paloalto juste à
côté de San Francisco regardez là vous
avez bien toute cette partie là cette
arche qui ressort très clairement
l'éclairage là qu'on voit bien on voit
bien toute la partie du fond tout est
bien maîtrisé au niveau de la lumière il
y a rien qui jure il y a rien qui crache
c'est bon sur l'ultra grand tempank ça
va aussi bien la nuit donc ça c'est
quand même super bien et après on peut
venir zoomer et se rapprocher et ça
c'est quand même très très bien avec moi
au centre la voyer ça marche aussi quand
même plutôt pas mal on me voit prendre
une photo depuis un hublot d'avion et
bien évidemment qu'est-ce qu'on voit et
bien on me voit parce que le hublot est
éclairé même si dehors il fait un petit
peu sombre et bien regardez ce que vous
faites c'est que vous venez vers le haut
vous balayez et là il vous proposera ce
qu'on peut faire effacer les reflets
remasterisés ici on veut venir effacer
les reflets j'appuie dessus donc là
l'intelligence artificielle va venir
analyser les reflets et elle les
supprime donc on me devine un peu ma
main très légèrement mais globalement il
y a pas grandchose donc ça c'est quand
même vachement vachement cool autre
photo par exemple là c'est une photo de
nuit prise au mode portrait et bien on
se dit qu'est-ce que lia va nous
proposer ici je swipe vers le haut et
elle va nous proposer ici un effet
d'arrière-plan bon bon pourquoi pas mais
surtout moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
fonction remasterisée comme ça je vais
pouvoir venir améliorer la qualité de ma
photo donc il vient bien évidemment
analyser votre image et là vous allez
venir switcher entre le avant après le
avant c'est un peu plus terne et le
après c'est quand même un peu plus
brillant c'est un peu plus sympa
regardez on le voit c'est hyper
impressionnant et surtout il a repéré le
visage on peut le faire directement sur
le visage voyez un peu plus terne un peu
plus coloré pareil de la même manière
ici je swipe remasteriser la
colorimétrie n'a plus rien à voir avant
c'est quand même beaucoup plus terne là
c'est beaucoup plus coloré beaucoup plus
saturé c'est plus efficace regardez là
par exemple j'ai une photo que je vais
venir modifier et bien lors que clique
sur mes petites étoiles sur la gauche
peux venir activer l'a et qu'est-ce qui
se passe et bien si je veux venir
décaler ma photo pour une raison pour
une autre je fais ce que je veux c'est
de l'artistique et bien j'ai toute une
partie où il y a pas de contenu et bien
ce que je vais faire c'est que je vais
cliquer sur Générer et là lia va venir
créer du remplissage de l'image en
venant créer du contenu qui n'existe pas
ça c'est lia générative mais c'est
extrêmement intéressant donc là il est
en train de calculer de définir un
nouveau décor et voyez il vous a rempli
votre are image avec des choses qui
n'existaient pas si j'affiche l'original
je suis comme ça et voyez tout le reste
le bâtiment à gauche il n'existait pas
la tour à droite elle n'existait pas le
petit cadre là et bien il n'existait pas
tout ça lia est venu le créer autre
élément dans cette photo je viens me
sélectionner moi j'ai envie d'être sur
la gauche bon pourquoi pas donc là hop
j'ai envie de m'agrandir et me mettre un
peu de travers sauf que sur la partie
centrale j'y suis plus donc qu'est-ce
que va faire lia elle va venir générer
du contenu au centre ça vient remplir
l'image ça vient créer du contenu ça
vient ajouter automatiquement des
éléments manquant donc là la magie est
en train d'opérer et regardez c'est
bluffant il m'a créé un contenu derrière
qui n'existait pas on voit bien les
tours qui sont là voyez je vous mets
l'original je suis comme là donc la tour
du centre et bien il manquit vachement
de contenu il l'a analysé et c'est
extrêmement partinent il y a une
nouvelle fonctionnalité qui est super
intéressante parce que vous faites de la
vidéo vous allez pouvoir avoir un
ralenti en posant directement votre
doigt sur l'écran en fait qu'est-ce qui
va se passer c'est une fois de plus
l'intelligence artificielle qui va venir
travailler elle va venir rajouter des
bouts d'images manquantes des frames
manquantes elle va venir les générer
artificiellement pour vous créer un
ralenti absolument incroyable incroyable
alors regardez je vous montre donc là
j'ai mon skater qui va arriver et hop il
arrive hop j'appuie et là j'ai un
ralenti et je vois la scène au ralenti
alors la voir me direz-vous c'est bien
l'enregistrer c'est mieux et bien c'est
facile vous venez ici sur le petit
crayon pour venir éditer et là vous
cliquez sur régler la vitesse la vitesse
la plus ralentie que je viens de
regarder c'est celle qui est en 1/4 donc
là régler la vitesse 1/4 et là je
choisis l'endroit où je veux mon ralenti
donc là hop il me le met juste là je
voudrais légèrement venir le modifier
voilà au moment où il commence à sauter
jusque au moment où il est par là voilà
tout ça je veux du ralenti toute la fin
de la vidéo là où il est au bout je
dirais que je m'en fiche un petit peu
est-ce que je veux un peu de contexte au
début là il est pas là voilà et là il va
faire son entrée juste là donc là je
veux juste avant son entrée et là je
peux regarder voyez je met lecture hop
il arrive il saute il est au ralenti et
ensuite je récupère le reste et là je
fais enregistrer donc comme ça jeisir ma
vidéo au
[Musique]
ralenti donc là on est en train de se
balader à San Francisco derrière je vois
qu'il y a une installation et je sais
vraiment pas ce que c'est je comprends
pas je vois un truc avec des miroirs des
mains mais globalement ça me parle pas
on va aller à la rencontre d'un d'un
monsieur derrière pour qu'il puisse
m'expliquer et je vais venir utiliser
mon samsung galaxy S24 ultra avec la
fonction interprète pour venir l'activer
c'est facile bien regardez hop là je
descends je vais dans mes paramètres là
j'ai la fonction interpréteur je clique
dessus en haut c'est de l'anglais donc
lui me parlera en anglais en bas c'est
du français moi je lui parlerai en
français là j'ai un petit bouton qui me
permet que moi j'ai j'ai la le le
message transcrit face à moi lui il a le
message transcrit face à lui et comme ça
on peut parler facilement est-ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer ce qui se passe
ici et qu'est-ce que c'est que tous ces
affichages
jaunes created by the Exploratorium
which is down ATER 15 it's a whole
bigger building but these are exhibits
that they created so um visitors like us
or you coming from out of state country
or whatever experience Exploratorium
without payingone
to c'est un bâtiment plus grand il
s'agit d'un bâtiment plus grand mais ce
sont les expositions qui ont été crées
pour les visiteurs qui aiment vous
pouvez venir de n'importe quel ét
expérience d'argent et VO un
constructeur et ok ok ce qu'ils ont fait
qui est cool c'est qu'ils ont mis un
petit QR code qui me permettra de venir
avoir plein d'informations dans
différentes langues sauf que là je vais
avoir en espagnol en chinois et en
anglais je l'ai pas en français ce que
je fais c'est que je prends ici mon
galaxy S24 ultra je viens devant je
scanne mon QR code ça m'emmène
directement ensuite sur l'explication
alors sur la page c'est la même chose
tout en anglais et je vois en haut j'ai
de l'anglais de l'espagnol du chinois
une fois de plus je suis un peu Laré et
bien je vais juste en bas là sur mes
petites icônes avec mes petites étoiles
pour venir déclencher lia je peux faire
un résumé dans un premier temps alors
mon résumé vous me direz il va être en
anglais j'ai pas mieux comprendre c'est
clair mais c'est là où la magie opère
c'est que là ensuite j'ai la fonction
traduire qui va venir me traduire mon
résumé de l'anglais vers le français je
peux choisir plein de langues et là je
vois ça permet d'explorer les
interactions sociales les scientifiques
ont étudié divers aspects des
interactions sociales y compris les
préjugés les stéréotypes l'humour la
générosité la compr rtion le tribalisme
cette installation invite les visiteurs
à s'engager dans des activités luiques
et des discussions sur les comportements
sociau humains donc voyez si si j'avais
pas cet outil là et ben si à moins que
je parle anglais bah je suis un peu
bloqué et un peu emmerdé donc là ça me
permet vraiment de voyager un peu à
travers le monde et de comprendre ce qui
se passe sans galérer sans avoir un
traducteur donc ça c'est le premier truc
alors là je vouslais montrer comme ça
mais là je vous avais fait un résumé
mais si je va pas faire de résumé bien
voyez je clique là je clique sur
traduire là je vais récupérer toute la
traduction de la page qui permettra de
comprendre plus en pro profondeur sur
que cette expo si je veux plus d'infos
et puis il y a plein de QR code à droite
à gauche ce qui fait que je les scanne à
chaque fois et grâce à mon smartphone et
bien jeis voir toutes les informations
et là voyez tirer une chaise parl là il
m'explique réellement de quoi il en est
qui organise ce qui se passe et comme je
suis sur le site après je peux venir
naviguer directement et aller plus en
profondeur dans
[Musique]
l'Info la traduction instantanée lorsque
vous êtes face à quelqu'un on l' essayé
ça marche alors des fois il y a quelques
petits mots qui bricolent ou c'est pas
parfait mais mais dans l'idée ça marche
à contrario j'ai utilisé par téléphone
là les gens la plart du temps ne font
pas l'effort et vous raccrochz parce que
je pense qu'il croit que c'est une Arna
il y en a quelques qui ont fait peu
l'EFF de rester d'écouter de parler avec
moi bonjour je n'ai pas encore réservé
je voulais savoir si vous aviez des
Tesla Model 3 à l'agence de San
Francisco s'il vous
plaît
oui c'est vraiment
[Musique]
fort d'accord bien sû je ser plus de
vous aider avec cela dans Je vair beso
de transférit
spéf debout au TourCom en bas vous a
libéré du café c'est noté merci
beaucoup on voit que par téléphone c'est
perfectible non pas à cause de la techno
parce qu'elle est là elle fonctionne et
même si elle est pas parfaite elle
fonctionne elle permet de venir
converser mais juste d'un point de vue
social aujourd'hui les gens ne savent
pas ne sont pas alertés ne sont pas
avertis il va falloir que Samsung
communique beaucoup sur ces
fonctionnalités là pour que le reste du
monde puisse le savoir et que enfin on
puisse avoir des échanges sans que les
gens vous raccrochent au DZ alors là je
vous ai montré effectivement en face à
face je vous ai montré par téléphone
mais il y a également une autre façon de
venir échanger directement et ça c'est
par message dans votre application
message vous venez trouver quelqu'un qui
va venir parler anglais ici j'ai breet
avec qui onenir converser et je vais lui
marquer un petit message coucou mon pote
es-tu toujours disponible pour déjeuner
à midi vous appuyez sur les trois petits
points que vous avez là et vous allez
sur traduction du chat et là vous
choisissez automatique vers l'anglais là
j'ai plus qu'envoyer AB directement le
message hello my bu avilable for lunch
no pouri cette fonction fctionalité elle
est géniale elle fonctionne très bien et
là pour le coup on comprend donc aucun
problème d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous
avez fait gaffe lorsque j'ai appuyis sur
le petit bouton petite icône qui me
permet d'avoir accès à l'intelligence
artificielle il y a une fonction qui
s'appelle style d'écriture et qui elle
est vraiment aussi pas mal du tout wesh
mec prêt pour la bouffe ou bien ça va
être terrible sauf que Bret c'est un
collègue de boulot et je peux pas lui
envoyer un message dans l'état donc ce
que je vais faire je clique sur la
partie avec la je vais dans style
d'écriture et là ça va venir analyser
mon texte et me proposer une dé version
alternative alors vous avez différents
styles là il vous met l'original WHM prê
pour la bouffe ou bien ça va être
terrible vous avez la version
professionnelle et ça c'est pas mal
parce que BR c'est un collègue de boulot
bonjour Je me permet de vous contacter
pour savoir si vous êtes intéressé par
un déjeuner d'affaires je pense que ce
serait une excellente occasion de
discuter de nos projets en cours et de
voir comment nous pouvons travailler
ensemble à l'avenir merci de me faire
savoir si vous êtes disponiblebl
cordialement on part quand même du
message qui est Wes mec pr pour la
bouffe ou bien ça va être terrible je
vous assure moi je sais pas pourquoi ça
fait mourir de rire alors vous avez le
détendu salut mec prêt pour la bouffe ou
quoi ça va être trop bon bon ok c'est un
peu dans la même dans la même histoire
et vous avez le social wesh mec prêt
pour la bouffe ou bien ça va être
terrible avec Emoticon pizza Emoticon
frites hashtag food porn hashtag miam et
vous avez le poli qui peut aussi être
pas mal bonjour comment allez-vous
êtes-vous prêt pour le repas ce sera
délicieux ce qui paraît pas mal ou alors
vous le transformez en emoji wesh mec
prêt pour la bouffe ou bien ça va être
terrible emoticin qui se lèche les
lèvres et avec emoticin couvert alors
moi je pense que ce qui va correspondre
abet c'est d'aller sur le détendu donc
là je clique sur Insérer ça vient donc
modifier mon texte c'est pas mal et
après de la même manière et bien
regardez je vais sur traduction du chat
et ensuite j'ai plus qu'à l'envoyer à
Bret et là ça va venir le traduire hey
man ready for the food or what it's
going to be too good alors attendez je
vous montre il aussi une autre
fonctionnalité qui est géniale et qui
est encore en bas qui vous permettra de
venir corriger votre orthographe ça va
je suis je mets pas de s au top du top
et là je vais aller sur ma petite partie
hop là je vais là je vais sur
orthographe et grammaire pour qu'il me
corrige ça quand même c'est terrible et
là il me l'écrit ça va il m'a bien mis
le CCD je suis il me corrige met bien en
S et au top du top et là il me met un
point donc voyez je clique sur Insérer
et ensuite comme j'aiécis à Bret une
fois de plus je vais là traduction du
chat c'est parti j'envoie ça à mon pote
Bret et là il écrit i'm on top comme ça
voyez c'est facile ça vient changer le
style l'améliorer corriger vos fa
d'orthograp traduire bref lia ici pour
les messages elle est absolument
incroyable
bon allez on a trouvé un copain dans le
coin collection vous connaissez la
chaîne bon alors je voulais vous montrer
la la fonctionnalité de transcription du
texte du transcription de l'audio donc
là on va dans l'application enregistreur
vocal et on va avoir une petite
conversation tous les deux salut JB ça
va ça va super bien et toi je suis au
top je voudrais savoir qu'est-ce que tu
penses du Galaxy S 24 ultra tu l'as vu
tout comme moi tu as commencé un peu à
t'amuser avec qu'est-ce que tu en penses
et quelles sont les fonctionnalités
principales que tu retiens toi ici alors
j'aime beaucoup surtout l'intelligence
artificielle qui est embarqué avec le
Galaxy ai la transcription bah des vocau
la transcription de la voix mais aussi
tout ce qui est traduction instantanée
que tu vas pouvoir faire par message
mais aussi par téléphone ça je trouve ça
génial bon voyez hop on fait ça comme ça
donc là on l'enregistre on met JB on va
sur la note vocale on va sur transcrire
ici en français bien évidemment donc là
il pour faire la transcription
salut JB ça va ça va super et toi je
suis au top bah ouais je voudrais savoir
qu'est-ce que tu penses du Galaxy S 204
uluata
bon sais ça me fait mal parce que je me
dis vraiment j'articule pas du tout quoi
ça le fait vraiment pas et on a la
transcription c'est pas parfait parfait
mais on a quand même la transcription on
va aller sur le résumé pour voir ce
qu'il arrive à nous générer comme résumé
ici discussion sur les caractéristiques
du Galaxy s204 part particulièrement
impressionné par l'intelligence
artificielle embarquée intéressé par la
transcription vocale et la traduction
instantannée c'est exactement ce que ça
c'est l'essentiel d'un résumé de ce que
j'ai pu dire ouais merci bon on va faire
du sport tu me fais tu fais peine
[Musique]
salut qui parle du Samsung Galaxy S24
ultra va forcément parler de son SPN
pour venir prendre des notes manuscrites
regardez il est ranger là bien
évidemment pouvez venir prendre des
notes directement convertir vos notes en
texte ça c'est pas tout nouveau par
contre ce qui est nouveau c'est l'ajout
de l'intelligence artificielle
directement dans l'application not
désolé j'écris très très très mal je me
suis appliqué au mieux que je puisse
faire vous cliquer sur le petit bouton
juste en bas ici et là il vous propose
plusieurs choses formater
automatiquement résumer corriger
l'orthographe ou traduire nous on va
aller sur formater automatiquement sous
forme de note de réunion nouveau
smartphone iladliia exinos 2400 très
performant belle autonomie bon pour le
gaming très joli précommande tarif
maîtrisé comme ça voyez vous avez
différents formats ça vous permet
d'avoir un truc très structuré sur vos
notes pour venir bosser directement et
ça c'est quand même très très efficace
de reconnaître il y a un autre élément
qui est super bien toujours dans l'IA
c'est la partie résumé le Galaxy S24 est
un nouveau smartphone doté d'une
intelligence artificielle d'un
processeur exyos 2400 d'une grande
autonomie et de bonnes performan de jeu
et puis ensuite on va venir retrouver
ici pour corriger l'orthographe nouveau
smartphone donc là il corrige ça il met
une majuscule parce qu'on met devant là
il met les majuscules et sinon le reste
c'est correct et puis ensuite on va
finir ici on va arriver sur la
traduction new smartphone EAS
performing well beautiful autonomy bref
very nice preorders price mastered comme
ça il a les infos c'est essentiel et ça
ça marche j'ai fait beaucoup de cahiier
d'écriture à l'école et croyez-moi ils
ont jamais réussi à venir corriger mon
écriture alors bien évidemment ici le
Samsung Galaxy S24 ultra aura du mal à
venir me relire et si vous avez une
écriture qui est bien meilleure que la
mienne soyez rassuré le Samsung Galaxy
S24 ultra vous aidera pour venir résumer
vos notes pour la mise en forme pour
venir vous corriger pour venir
structurer et c'est vrai que l'outil est
extrêmement
[Musique]
performant et clou du spectacle en plus
si vous l'achetez sur Samsung.com vous
avez des couleurs exclusives en plus du
gris titane du noir titane du violet
titane et de l'ambre titane que vous
avez là et qui sont juste très très très
très jolis et bien vous avez le bleu
titane couleur exclusive Samsung.com que
j'adore qui est très très beau également
le vert titane sans oublier le orange
titane les nouveaux Samsung Galaxy S24
S24 plus et s 24 ultra avec ce modèle là
sont les premiers smartphones à
réellement aller entièrement dans la
nouvelle aire de l'intelligence
artificielle sur smartphone je trouve ça
vraiment bluffant on peut commencer
reapercevoir le futur de là où on va
aller au niveau des applicatifs grâce à
nos smartphones que ce soit pour venir
échanger avec les gens que soit pour
venir créer du contenu que ce soit pour
un côté professionnel le Samsung Galaxy
S24 ultra vous permettra d'aller
beaucoup plus loin de moins vous prendre
la tête d'être beaucoup plus efficace
c'est pour moi une très jolie découverte
d'ailleurs si ce smartphone vous
intéresse je vous mets bien évidemment
un lien juste en bas dans la des alle
parce que c'est vraiment un smartphone
qui est très très très très bluffant et
d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas vu ma
vidéo d'astuce sur One 6 foncez la
découvrir vous verrez également plein de
nouvelles fonctionnalités pour encore
mieux utiliser votre Samsung Galaxy S24
ultra